[Music]
hello how is it going
hope you're having a good week I'm kind
of happy especially this week because
the chest clip is officially open
limited to the limited number of people
but still being open is better than just
being close right
so let's see what other news do I have
so today I wanted to show you a little
bit about one of my favorite books the
Giants of strategy this is pretty old
book I think that's 2009 by Neil
McDonald and I really like this book
because it has so many interesting
features to offer okay and one of the
things that I really really liked about
it was I did a video about how to beat
Kasparov in ten steps that was actually
from this book I believe I did say that
back then - and yeah so they have a
specific chapter that they called it
some planning on a grand scale and I
really like that one because it has so
much mix of strategy and tactics and
it's just everything so I kind of wanted
to show you guys a little bit of that
and yeah let's see how is my favorite
book doing and feel free to send me your
favorite book recommendations and we can
go check those out too so let's look at
this board that we have is just from
beginning this is a game between named
Zoe she and Rubenstein in 1926 almost a
hundred years ago getting there so new
is just white and I did also read the
book nimzowitsch wrote one of them the
my system one and I really really liked
that one too I feel like one when I look
at it right now just feel the little
like some stuff could them could be a
little bit updated or improved but
that's really helped my chess
understanding this was like a big
stepping stone for me so if you feel
like you have a lot of time and you want
to read some book that's a interesting
book to read doesn't have to accept
everything he says but it was a very
nice point of view hello from India nice
okay so I'm not really going to focus on
the opening match because it's just a
typical opening and it's just a
symmetrical English it's not that much
to it and the lines have been updated in
the past hundred years so we're not
going to worry about opening too much
but what I really like is the pawn
structure that they get out of it so
just looking at the pawn structure just
right here right now you can see that
okay so this Bishop is groups
I've gotten to I've gotten used to which
assigned them just that to come that I
can just click and it's highlights it
haha alright so this Bishop is pretty
okay well placed this Knight is
definitely going to get kicked away at
some point you don't know exactly when
there's going to be a for coming up
later just looking at the pawn structure
these are the little things that you
could pick up what else what else one
thing that you don't Basilian as what
are you going to do to it this Bishop I
mean ideally if you get a four a five
then all right this Bishop is good place
here could come out to a four like you
can just eyeball it as you're going but
the one thing that you do know is that
you are you do want f4 so that's
something that you can work on well and
again not right now cuz your knight is
under attack but just looking at what
the position has to offer
okay so we do this mighty to our idea
we're still supporting this a4 idea now
b5 is coming up right so um I wouldn't
really recommend something like a four
because you just give this outpost
tonight I mean you would stop some b5
but it's it's a very drastic pun change
a key change position it's a very
drastic contrivance that changes your
position forever and this nights always
going to be welcomed here I don't know
if you like I would be ready to make
that commitment so I wouldn't play a
four that's just my reasoning and also
your game is much more concentrated in
the center and in the kingside and
that's what you would want to go for
right so let's say if you play you're 93
as nimzowitsch did get your f for
finally all right now my first question
for you white to move what do you want
to do hello from Nepal extremely
explosive opening yeah actually that is
true it's pretty explosive right so you
have a lot of options are you ready to
start pushing these pawns do you feel
like kicking this night away do you want
to bring out some clean some rook some
bishop I'm just trying ideas with you
and I'm going to wait to see some
replies and just get a good vibe of what
you guys are thinking about so yeah just
let me know what are you feeling what do
you want to do and we will go from there
all right so I have a five line nice
hello say hi to my daughter
[Music]
Genesis nice hello
1400 is not a bad rating don't worry we
all start somewhere and to continue to
Dilip reply many coach is going to be
good but it's more important for you to
have the time to actually sit down and
learn on your own too so if you have the
time why not let's see so we have Queen
f3 Queen g3 that's a little eagle I
assume you wanted Queen g4 Excel Queen
f3
hello from Kenya hello Bishop d2 of 5-5
okay so basically these are the three
moves that you guys want and you want
this Queen to you well somewhere
depending on where you there is um it's
being nicely to support a fortress and
d4 uh hello Brian Clark I remember you :
I'm thinking so nice to you just
actually brought the knight from c3 to
you from c3 to e 2 and then you'd rent
this to g3 even though nighty to might
look a little bit attempting to attack
this you're actually never going to take
it because of Bishop c5 and you would
get pinned and well attacked so I don't
think that's a very accurate move so
well that's the note 2 nice e 2 e 3 is
interesting Adrienne is definitely
something that I would also consider
[Music]
okay so I'm glad with the responses I
got I also do kind of like queen g4 but
my problem is that Queen g4 this is
something to just be cautious about I
mean II 5 it's not like a real horrible
threat 5 now this Bishop is also open
Bishop f6 could be coming it's like not
the end of the world but and also I
don't really necessarily think that he
would play 85
and also another thing to keep in mind
this f5 doesn't really work because this
is pen so queen g4 looks interesting to
me as well
how about h4 h4 is something that
potentially could happen later on but
your position is not ready for it Jason
and you know anytime they live okay so I
am a big fan of all the moves that you
guys said but Queen f3 is kind of one of
those silent killers because another
thing to actually keep in mind is that
black has to somehow gets like developed
kinks and the Queen side right so one
way that black could potentially do it
is with b5 and right now something like
b5 there could be this explosive 'if
ives as well moves Bishop back now what
you want to do with your bishop now
again f5 could be coming up and just it
kind of keeps an eye on the King Queen
side as well I keep calling this King
side I don't know why actually I know
why I've been playing way too much for
player chess
ah guilty pleasure yeah I keep on mixing
my sides right now but besides that back
to some real chess yeah clean f3 is
another that just keeps an eye on this
as well and kind of weakens the Queen
side too so in the King Rubinstein
played King f8 and so the idea is yeah
okay so I don't know if you meant Bishop
t2 before king educate or right now but
yes Bishop t2 right now Bishop d2 is
very strong because true you like d2 is
not going to be the final diagonal for
your Bishop because it's not doing its
best but ooh Sydney you do have a good
memory I do think this is that one - Wow
yeah it is that one all right certainly
very very nice memory okay so the idea
with which this is one of this classic
so it is possible that you guys have
seen at least some positions of these
not necessarily the whole game but yeah
I'm impressed
nice okay so this 52 it's kind of like
one of those moves that you're waiting
you're still trying to see what's going
on you are trying to provoke opponents
to potentially remove the night that's
another thing is you don't you still are
not sure if you want a five you want f5
you want to remove the rook you still
are not sure what you want to do so
preferably don't just make a commitment
like a five and then be like oops that's
not exactly what I want it so it's okay
no spoilers yeah okay well don't worry I
didn't say which move will run so just
maybe an iTouch five could be coming up
but my first one
Knights are not managed well Marty so I
could come up to who knows but my point
being that didn't give real spoilers
still still pretty interesting okay so
after Bishop t2 what do you think black
should do that's a good question right
do you want to push some pawns do you
want to develop Queen side also why do
you think black played this King whoops
nope that's not the move why do you
think black plays King is raised right
now is this Oh could I at some point in
the future play tournaments without
having a chess go up like real Freitas
tournaments I mean I'm Annie technically
yes I don't think really you need to
have a chess club to forfeit it great at
tournaments but also the rules are a
little bit different in us then where I
give it up so I'm sure it's easy to find
feeder tournaments to play well after
there are tournaments to be played all
right let's go back oh yeah I remember
you génesis rodríguez and
time glad to have you Quincy 727 is um
interesting but how does King h8 flows
with Queen c7 and yes to play f5 yep you
are correct
oh boy then okay I have problem with
pronunciations as you guys all know who
have washed me once every single time I
struggle with pronunciation so I
apologize from mispronouncing from right
now and future apologies to be made too
but yes I five years to play a five that
is correct
a few people mention this and all right
so f5 is the idea that's is supported by
this King h8 because it's kind of kind
of simple kind of interesting because so
even though white still hasn't mm shown
his hand with f5 or e5 black is kind of
growing impatient and just wants this
this pressure to be off because so I got
I've been getting some questions well so
where is the psychology behind chess on
psychology that's we call this class and
sometimes I do forget to completely walk
you through my thought process and it's
like okay so in this position right now
it's not just about which move is the
best because I find a secret move if I
was a good move and they both are going
to have consequences because like if you
play e5 well the bishop is going to move
and this could potentially become like
f5 could come up so breathe thank you
but so my point being that it is
actually a very interesting thing that's
white isn't necessarily playing this f5
or a5 because in the game like just
imagine yourself sitting there
you're playing as black your opponent
has all these opportunities with f5 and
ef5 you are going to go a little
impatient and either make a mistake or
if not making a mistake you're just you
can't I mean it's really hard to handle
the pressure of just sitting there and
waiting it feels like Lee I'm sitting
duck so that's the way I would feel just
sitting there
I can't develop my queenside can't bring
up my work what is about my night doing
up here so yeah so just that the
psychological pressure is also something
that would kind of be a little hard to
deal with so there's your psychology of
the day and so yes that is actually just
thinking about how I would feel and
trying to explain that that's the way I
would definitely feel definitely under
pressure just like oh boy so that's
another thing
so f5 now a question for you guys do you
think whites should take it white should
push it or why should ignore it well
those are basically your three choices
and so yeah just let me know what do you
want to do and to tell you to be
completely honest mmm I know I wouldn't
take on a five so now choosing between a
five or completely ignoring it I I don't
know which one I would choose just first
look I would check to see if there is
anything more to e5 if not just so right
now again this is another way to like
implement a little bit more pressure on
your opponent at least psychologically
because so if you are not taking it and
if you're not pushing it this tension is
always going to be there and it's like
one of those constants moves that so you
know for yourself I'm not gonna take it
I'm not gonna push it
but the opponent's every single move he
has to calculate okay so do I want to
push now do I want to take now it's just
one of those do one of those things
yes I'm an eb-5 would make
he seeks a little bit more week but it
would also give this diagonal to black
because now black could easily play
something like this and your Bishop
won't be able to make the best of itself
and now this a 8 H 1 diagonal would
actually belong to black so be careful
with that rook to d1 take take pressure
yeah I rook e1 I kind of reckon one is
the best one because so I understand
your idea with rook d1 you're looking
one makes sense
if he takes it because now you actually
that you are correct you do have this
pressure on d4 but yeah your key one is
the best one because I it so yes you are
not going to necessarily take on f5
right away but you you do have that
option so having your rook on e 1
whenever you choose to take on f1 f v
then this rook is also opened up so yeah
that's something to keep it keep an eye
out if he takes on e4 i mm I like to
just take back with the pawn and push
for f5 the next few moves now Queen s5
is also possible you can even just try
to go for some cool nights if possible
I've been doing some cheap tactics
recently just trying to find a mate all
right yeah taking with Mike is also very
interesting I was a little worried if I
take with the knight what happens with E
5 because I was kind of a little
skeptical by I guess just taking over
here makes sense you don't really need
to worry about it that much all right no
this is good don't worry about that
white is good in there
yeah exactly taking what the knight is
also very interesting I think both
taking with pawn or Knight are
interesting especially a knight on e4
another plus that it has oops
is this 95 and going after h7
potentially and also e6 is pretty weak
this night could actually attack that so
yeah nicely done
I take right now I'm more leaning
towards taking and not taking with night
because like what are you gonna do this
should be 7 that's okay what about Queen
s5 now I could consider f5 even more
seriously okay there are five opening up
this bishop things are good
the one thing that taking with night
makes worries me a little is to put the
possibility of 95 so those are some
things to look out for all right let's
go back to the game so we're gonna shine
did not take the pawn on e4 and he just
went to knight c6 so 96 is a cool move
nothing wrong with it I'm just trying to
regroup some pieces reorganize material
it's perfectly fine so in the game names
always tried to well he played really -
I think Rokita is another one of those
little psychological moves because
turkey 2 is not actually having anyone
move threats but turkey - it does have
potential for doubling the rooks up
wherever necessary
potential of trying to somewhat if
necessary again bring Bishop to the King
side just it has a lot of potential it's
not necessarily like like if you look at
this position you're not gonna be yeah
rook eater is the first move I want to
play yeah exactly caveman style yeah but
your key too is pretty nice and Ricky -
does serve a lot of purposes and I can
only hope that I would be able to find
it in my games ah ok so black tries to
develop a little bit put more pressure
now why to move do
you think are you ready to do anything
with epon do you want to push do you
want to take do you wanna do some cruel
manoeuvre somewhere just let me know
what you want to do hmm also another way
to think about it is so you'd like you
can you can look and see that you have
this positional advantage and you can
also see that white has definitely
special advantage and this pawn this d4
phone is somewhat cut off from the rest
of the black pieces and it could
potentially become a cool targets what
else what else is good for white bishop
on c4 is pretty good for whites right
it's kind of has a very nice style you
know well not necessarily right now but
if you decide to take what else what
else you could potentially start forming
a attack on the kingside because of your
strong bishop over here because the King
can't just scape that's just like king
would become like that's just not going
to be really possible now you want to
look on c1 right yeah you're correct
with me Queen c7 is kind of the sad
point but also Queen c7 is a very very
natural and very like everyday move
because like you kind of do need to
develop but how and I don't really see
any other way like something like Bishop
d7 I mean it's possible but like what
are you doing with this Bishop the other
things that quit but could we could
think about is if this Queen was already
in the Queen in the Kings side it could
kind of cover up the king of it no but
Queen e8 can't really happen because of
this pen
same with queenie seven and just to just
show you Queenie f6 is also a blunder
so don't blunder and so yes that's I
think Rubinstein kind of broke under the
pressure and plays Queen c7 alright so
you guys want diagonal you want to
prevent Knight a5 so you guys want to
start pushing an h4 goal that's a lot of
different ideas alright so I already
spoke a little bit about the potential
advantages that's white could have right
so thinking about just trying to do an
assessment is like it might not be
enough because like I spoke about this
week pawn I spoke about this strong
Bishop and potentially having some open
files or disguise for districts but like
it's it's let's look at this take take
so just looking at it do you feel this
position favors white or black I mean I
like white I hope you guys also like
white right now just because of the
positional and spacial advantage and
this open rook and this open bishop am i
convincing enough somehow okay so the
other way to think about it is if black
has just two moves black is going to
play like Bishop d7 turkey 8 and why
it's advantage is kind of just not as
visible anymore
becomes one of those imaginary
advantages okay that was kind of cool
and and yeah so okay so that's kind of
what I wanted to talk about like doing a
little bit of assessments of the
position and all right what else can we
think about
well as whites you kind of have to can
start considering to actually for a real
attack to Black's King right so my
question is how can you start attacking
blacks King why I love Bishop d7
volatile it's white to move so you don't
like I mean you can't come up with other
rules if you want to but true but taking
on f5 is actually a good move because I
can understand why you guys would prefer
a five but at the same time if you were
to play e5 this efile is always going to
give up this diagonal to black also
another routes to take is this Knight d5
square is completely gonzo so that's why
I'm not the biggest fan of a five ooh I
see some stuff in Chad's some spoiler
alerts okay um so also if with Queen c7
you were just going to keep on waiting
with light again this could happen again
this Bishop e7 Turkey eight and you
still don't have any any clear attack as
white so that's why I would try to be a
little bit more a little bit more
energetic and take on f5 and okay I see
your idea in the chat be sure you are
considering something with Bishop d5 to
just have this as well yes you are
correct
Bishop d5 is an interesting idea but
there is another interesting move Thank
You excel yeah so right now all of your
pieces are doing something well to be
honest this Bishop could be this d2
Bishop I mean ideally it could be in a
better position but you don't really see
any clear path for it's right and it
does
actually doing something it's maybe
protecting this guy taking this squares
away so it's not completely useless the
one piece that is completely useless
right now is this night isn't it so that
is why we do this cool move over night
h1 and blue 931 right so it's a very
awesome and cool move and yeah exactly
the night wasn't doing anything on g3 so
you want to relocate it simply you want
to go up to g5 an attack h7 remember how
earlier we were talking about if in a
different position
same game if black were to play F you
foul Fe for you want to take with night
and still have that 95 yeah these are
some like stuff that that night belongs
on g5 especially especially with this
weakness on h7 and f7 you just you need
this night on g5 like like you need that
night on g5 you mind you got a better
find anyway right okay so I hope I
emphasize this night on g5 enough so
let's say Bishop goes to d7 you follow
up with your plan Rubenstein follows up
with his plan you can't completely
ignore this plan because you still want
to keep your pieces ideally and you also
want to be able to keep your your file
right so that's why you would just play
your Rick and rook e1 take take and now
so question for each for you guys do you
think e8 is a good move if not can you
tell me why not also Bashar yes nice
going to g5 does cost a lot of moves
that's why it's such a brilliant move
it's like it's costing you up like four
moves yes but also it's the it's a move
that the position needs and if you don't
play this move
this is a maneuver of Knight to g5 you
don't really see any other way to
improve the night right so I understand
how it's hard to see it would definitely
be hard for me to actually make that
decision too but I'm hoping that's you
guys would at least consider it
after seeing some positions like this
you could consider okay so my night is
pretty horrible on g3 how can I make it
go a little bit better right so you
would consider something like night each
one and you would try to evaluate its
benefits or its its cons pros and cons
yeah I do a pros and cons list right in
the game no please don't do that in your
mind but do that in your mind alright so
yes rook e8 is not the best move because
of take take and Queen d5 so Edward
thing you mentioned Queen d5 earlier you
do have the right idea just maybe a
little bit like Philip those moves okay
Queen d5 is the best idea and it's
pretty simple I want mate
I mean you can't get any more simple
than that if something like Knight e5
now I just eat pawns nothing wrong with
eating some nice palms right and now
this is a very advantageous and I'm not
entering but some pieces are kind of
exchange off kinga's dupes King is is
still pretty weak this g7 is pretty weak
Bishop c3 coming next
now your bishops are monstrous and yep
everything good right okay so yeah
exactly to be continued with Bishop c3
so that's why your interests I'm played
98th 19th I think it's a very
interesting move yeah late middle game
middle game slash soon to come end game
for mate so 19th is interesting because
it could be like 96 all right
seven and taking by controlling this
tree five square so when we are trying
to do that so I think that's why in IT
it is a very interesting move and trying
to just keep away is nine three five and
also potentially looking for Bishop c6
that's another thing so you consider and
yeah so now the other thing to consider
is well now with night on th this is
also a very weak pawn so keep that in
mind as we move forward so let's say we
do our night is three Bishop c6 you get
your cleanup Queen is five is pretty
essential because takes this eh away so
be careful with that I have a question
after night shipping finally appears why
not h6 oh that's a good question I
actually I'm doing some some of the
camps before the club and we actually
looked at a position very similar to
this mates idea so that the problem is
aren't so I'm going to just do a weird
move that did not happen in the game
just because I want to show what is
wrong with h6 so if h6 white has a very
cool idea of mating pretty much mating -
can anyone tell me you guys got this
just need someone to type it
they won't feel like typing oh boy
oh I'm waiting I'm waiting yes thank you
Sydney yeah so the the problem is still
Queen g6 and if you were to take on g5
again Queen Azshara now that's another
type of meat if you don't take now its
Queen whoops not queen r7 is made right
thank you thank you everyone for
participating in my questions and yes
Queen g6 is the best one the one thing
that sometimes we tend to forget is so
you are attacking the square nothing to
sell this pawn so even with h6 the pawn
move but the square still is there so
you are still able to go after that okay
so I just wanted to show you this idea
with mates but obviously Rubinstein
sighs and he were not going to allow 95
h6 to happen so that is why black tries
to play something like g6 something like
h6 still not g5 and now the again Queen
g6 is coming up what black could
potentially do is take on a four right
and now if Queen g6 you could just take
on g5 right so my question to you right
now it is white to move what do you want
to do black just took your pawn on f4 do
you see any cool checks any cool takes
or any cruel attacks doesn't have to be
cool just any kind of glance over that
checks takes and moves with threats
so night of seven is interesting night a
six is interesting but there's something
way more interesting rook e8 Sam be
careful the bishop is still on c6 kooky
seven rookie Saunders queen e7 so still
a lot of things to be careful what else
what else
so the one thing that I think we all
agree on is that we don't really wants
to do this Bishop f4 right because
official before Queen afore and now the
queen is the one who is participating in
the attack and we don't want that
oh I'm Anna you're good so take yeah
tactile talking about taking on f4 he
can just take back and now my question
is what do you want to do with your
nights cuz queen g6 doesn't work anymore
just Queen g5 rookie six ah I'm not sure
which position you are referring to
rookie six well it won't work right now
again because of Queen g5 but yeah so
Rick that's like take I the one thing I
wouldn't do is take I mean among other
if they're brothers but I wouldn't play
official before just because it brings
the Queen back in even if something like
nine f7 is looks interesting it's still
going to be pretty painful your this
queen is very like way more active than
I ever want any Queen to me just Queen
g5 and I mean it's it's it's kind of
hard to it gives your opponent chances
to sleep away and we don't want slippery
opponents right so I did have this
recommendation of Bishop before from I
Manny before so yeah Bishop before is
interesting because Bishop before
if you move your roof no I just have a
simple rookie aides and if you don't
move your work if you put something like
Bishop d6 to block this now I have my
queen g6 right take just queen is five
bye-bye alright so I wanted to kind of
show you what would happen if h6 and now
let's look at G 6 so this position white
to move g6 you have very limited options
you only have basically Queen h4 and
queen is six so my question for you is
what do you want do you and Queen h4 or
d1 Queen h6
Bosh are not entirely sure when you were
talking about Rick f2 but if it was
after Bishop takes Bishop Queen take on
f4 rook if til you have to be very
careful cuz Queen g5 still exists all
right yeah I have preferred cleaners for
- um Queen h6 is again my problem with
finish six is this Queen g7 that just
the Queen just just stumbles in the king
silence start saving the day so I don't
want that that's why I would want the
Queen - four but if you feel like
winners for doesn't really go with your
understanding is perfectly fine - you
can think more about it if queen is six
Queens you seven makes more sense to you
why not
alright so another little bit of piece
of trap a little bit of piece of trap
that's a lesson you think that we're
laying for opponents now I feel like I'm
laying a red carpet of traps for my
opponents which I would hope I would
like to is that if black was to play
something like rook e8 now you get to
take take and do this cool queen of six
if Queen goes to g7 you just pick this
guy up or even I mean d8 up I feel I
feel like T it is doing better I mean
they're both equally good they're both
pieces we love pieces right
you think pieces is always fun so that's
another little trip little trick that
you can hope you can Lancer your
opponent and alright so right now let's
say black points pretty nice and plays
the screen g7 so King g7
Black is just defending this potential
Queen of six of Queen of h6 and still
your knight is just a problem so but
right now your knight is better than a
h3 then on g3 because if you're not
using g3 first of all your Queen was
kind of blocked on h4 second of all this
night on g3
you know it does have potential for
sacrifices but knight on h3 is also
protecting your f4 pawn and it gives
your queen chance to regroup
how to remove d4 yeah I like that idea
let's go remove d4 why not so yeah you
are coming up to attack this d4 also as
soon as you're you you were able to open
the center up a little bit this bishop
seater is going to be very deadly so
that is another thing to consider all
right so let's see another thing that I
wanted to talk about was ooh here black
has basically two two chances well two
moves to try and defend d4 pawn that's
the better phrase one of them is with
Queen b6 and Klinger six is just kind of
just defending but it's not doing any
kind of real threat I I feel like Queen
b6 is a very similar idea to just Bishop
c5 you just have to defend that pawn no
matter what because if you lose the pawn
on d4 then the game is pretty much over
just bishops victory and you might as
well start scoring more pieces and pawns
and yeah alright so right now it's white
to move you are attacking this pawn on
d4 now the question is how can you bring
in more pieces to attack it's whoa
that was my bad I'm not entirely sure
why my mouse is slipped all right
everything's back to normal
everything good whew okay and I'm sorry
for the blinking chessboard all right so
now yep you are correct and eb4 is the
best one I want to remove light Bishop
to but I think d4 would be easier well
yes but also you are bishop on c4 is
pretty strong and yeah yeah you are also
corrects Queen b6 it does bring up the
question with Bishop c3 I think still
Bishop c5 could potentially like be the
only move again I think we have before
because it takes just take that and this
isn't it I mean it looks kind of scary
pawn but I don't think there's much to
it's because Queen d4 is coming and you
can just pick this guy up also yes also
yes Turkey 7 is another strong idea so
Queen b6 there are a lot of things to be
careful if Queen b6 but bishop p c5
b4 Bishop e6 now this bishop feels like
it's kind of just completely just put
out of the position and just like the
only thing it's doing is just look
defending this pawn where it should this
bishop was way more active and way more
defensive when the bishop was on d6
right now alright and also I like the
idea of Bishop c1 yes but you have
something a little bit more interesting
so what's the difference in the blacks
position
what sweetness is created comparing
Bishop being on d6 or being on b6
hmm I see I see you I'm Annie
Queenie one interesting Queenie one
you're going after a 587 square I assume
you have another way of attacking it as
well so rookie fun is another
interesting move but nuts right now
right now you have the chance to
activate your queen again yep Queen ash
for you guys are correct so this was
also a very very interesting idea to try
and reactivate the Queen it's I I find
it's very very interesting it's just
it's extremely great that's how he did
it's just very simple moves he didn't do
anything crazy or sacrifice bunch of
stuff everything very very very
calculator is very interesting very just
simple the moves that you could see it's
not something that would require a lot
of calculation and Queenie one is also
interesting but Queen Ashford is having
a more direct impact on the Kings side
so let's say something like Rocky eight
what would you do after Ricky eight yeah
ideally we want to have the rook on
seventh rank but after rook e8 you have
also another interesting move be careful
with ninety five ninety five is
interesting I just realized I keep
saying interesting but it's yes you are
attacking age seven but what would you
do with age six ninety six I just kind
of takes it so what else
do you see any interesting outposts you
might want to use
oh yeah yeah actually you are correct
working five is the best move that is
pretty simple if you take with if you
take my rib take tank now I just have
basically made in to well I mean
technically it could be a little bit
longer and actually it's not too -
that's about it just qui near six if you
try with something funny with king of
six I can just do Bishop g5 if you try
King is eight queen of eight and that's
a wrap for this game right okay so
that's why rookie five is a very
interesting move because black cannot
take on e5 because of how weak the king
is and just remember this Bishop used to
be on d6 protecting e7 protecting you
five now Bishop is on b6 doing
absolutely nothing so that was a very
interesting idea to bring the Queen back
up to attack d4 and force the bishop to
just go to b6
so let's say whack try something with
Knight f7 to try to kick your rook away
what do you want to do
so quiets everyone's thinking about how
beautiful this position is naturally I
was interesting but so will 95 I'm going
to just take on e5 would you take on it
seven and then what take on e5 I mean
it's definitely interesting but yeah it
gives a lot of chances to slip away so
yes you are correct best move is Bishop
of seven you gotta take it with the
Queen because if you take it with the
King the pawn is falling and so after
taking it with the Queen now you guys
get this Knight g5 that's we've been
waiting for since what like 12 hours ago
was that yeah move 18 we played at 91
and this is move 30 who finally got 95
so yay and yeah so 95 attacking Queen
and the h7 bishop so when g8 is pretty
much forced now question for the chat
what do you want to do with your other
pieces so do you feel like is your
attack very strong and you don't need to
regroup anything whoa or if you think
you can't improve pieces how could you
potentially maybe bring some Queen back
somewhere maybe exchange the rooks maybe
yeah Danny you're right
it's the best idea to exchange this
rooks whoa exchange these tricks and
then bring the Queen back to e1 so now
Knights a six is yeah I kind of hit the
table knight c6 is coming up 27 is
coming up let's see what else is coming
up the one thing that's still bugging me
is this bishop and we
he needs to do something about that so
let's see what would black soo let's say
black just plays Bishop c6 you get your
queen e7 you get this King is a now you
can't see that this King is just kind of
asking for this Bishop to come into this
diagonal and say hello and mate so how
can you get that how can you activate
your d2 Bishop almost there
just need one more Bishop to wrap up
this game so nice epsilon is interesting
but let's say just King goes to g7 you
give a check King goes back you take
this I mean it's possible you can just
pick this piece up nothing wrong with
that but it's not I mean ideally if you
don't see a way to activate your bishop
this is a very safe way to play it you
pick up a bishop you're going to win
this game so it's a kind of a risk-free
way to win it
so nothing wrong with that Oh Thank You
Dennis hello from Zimbabwe well I I was
actually in South Africa 2014 so thank
you it was a very nice country all right
let's go back to the position this is
the move I'm talking about and I saw
some players mention it the nice one
haruka-san
excel anyone else who I forgot sorry
about that but so b5 ISM yeah nice one
matey so b5 the idea is if you take now
I am just going to so Capitan fancy your
idea of 96 could be played here now 96
if black should play something like h5
because what else to playing you get
Bishop before and now you are going to
go
I got an error sign now you get to bring
your bishop the other way that's
something like Bishop DAA well you could
just prolong wait for a little bit but
you can't completely put it away I think
it's just taking that set I don't see
any other reason not to eat a free
bishop if you play something like Bishop
d5 I can just give check and give
another check
and Bishop f8 rap that came up yeah
why is nighty six necessary why not so
the thing is if you were to put a bishop
before what would you do after Bishop
d89 f7 I mean I think that's pretty safe
way to win I okay let me rephrase I
don't think that knight c6 is extremely
necessary like if you don't point 96
you're not going to win this game but 96
makes makes it way way way more
pressured because now after 96 black
cannot touch this Queen because queen g7
is mates this Bishop doesn't really have
anywhere to go if Bishop d5 then well
that's just that's also another problem
with the position I'm thinking about can
I just move the knight back one another
way can I just play 95 and try to go for
for this yeah this King is very very
just just under pressure so 96 just puts
away more pressure also yeah any time
glad you guys are
Mike eNOS because this is a very cool
position alright so we were talking
about age 5 to try and open some room
for breathing we said that we talked
about Bishop d5 here and Bishop d5 here
you have Queen f6 and also oops
sorry my bad I forgot to mention I don't
know why I said Knight c5 just queen up
six and that's just way easier win my
bad
yes so 96 you are putting pressure and
you're also threatening mate so I have
forgot to mention about the mate part
happens we have make left and right
right okay but joking aside this is a
very cool idea 96 just brings way way
too much advantage to the game and you
can mate with Bishop on f8 right all
right so let's go back and just a little
bit more let's say black plays Queen g7
and that's what black did in the game
Rubinstein plays Queen g7 one last try
to try and just prolong it a little bit
so what to move what do you want to do
do you think it's time to do some Queen
exchange and win a piece or do you just
want to keep on trying to check and
attack and what do you want to do the
tag or eat a piece
not entirely sure what's going on in the
chat but thank you for wanting mate mmm
this should be for an out of seven
honestly it's there's nothing wrong with
just taking on g7 and just taking a
piece I mean it's the safe way to go and
that's what news I wish did - I think
Queen g7 is just like a desperate try to
prolong the game but I mean Rubenstein
must have known that's where the piece
down he doesn't really have much real
chances so yeah I mean if you want to
you cannot I mean you can just not take
it and try to prolong it's a little
longer but this just gives a lot of
chances for blunders and mistakes which
could easily be avoided like I'm sure
this is like looking at it's it just I
mean this has to this just you can
easily play something like Bishop a5
whoops no that just goes back there my
idea was to try and get my Bishop to d4
eight dots and this is an interesting
game should be winning we'll see how it
goes but it's why why wouldn't you just
eat up a piece all right
knight of seven king g8 bishop before
this what do you do after Queen of seven
careful careful I'm Annie yeah don't
stone the tip on slip and you're almost
there
no sleeping so better just take it take
the piece just relocates just wear it to
put that night on c4 and just protect
your pawns try to exchange a little bit
go after more pawns and try to eat some
more pawns just very chill and this is
actually where Rubinstein resigned and
it was like a this was one of the
greatest strategy games that I've seen I
mean there are a lot of them out there
but this is definitely on my favorite
list
the other thing that I kinda wanted to
mention was I thought it was kind of
funny that white didn't really touch the
king
just made a cast on it was okay king is
their king is safe let's attack now
let's eat pieces let's go to n team and
that was kind of interesting and I just
wanted to mention that and yeah all
right that's I actually had about like
four games prepared to show you to the
hey but this was a very interesting and
it took all of our time but don't worry
we'll do a poll for next week to see if
you guys would like to see more stuff
like this and if you do I have a lot of
material this is also a great book that
you can also find and look for yourself
as well but yeah I'm glad you guys
enjoyed it have fun
tuning for daro and endgame and see you
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]